حياكم الله في العراق قتل جنديان عراقيين
واصيبا ثلاثه اخرون بجروح في هجوم بعبوه
ناسفه لم تتبنه اي جهه بعد استهدف
اليهما في محافظه كركوك في شمال العراق
وفق ما نقلت وكاله الانباء العراقيه
الرسميه واوضحت الانباء ان الجنود كانوا
يستقلون مركبه تابعه للجيش في منطقه مخمور
عندما انفجرت عبوه ناسفه فيها
مصدر امني وكاله فرانسبريس ان عناصر من
داعش فجروا عبوتين ناسفتين استهدفتها
عربتين عسكريتين قبل ان يطلق النار من
اسلحه رشاشه
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله ينضم الينا من بغداد فاضل لابو
رغيف الباحث في الشؤون الامنيه والسياسيه
ومن عمان ينضم الينا رعد هاشم الباحث في
هشام العراقيه اهلا بكما ليبدا اولا من
بغداد مع السيد فاضل سيد فاضل يعني هجمات
متكرره على رجال الامن ربما ثلاثه خلاله
اسبوع ما الذي يحدث
نعم استاذ عادل تحيه طيبه لك والمشاهدي
قناتك الكريمه ولضيفك الاستاذ ذرعات هاشم
يعني اولا هناك جمله اسباب كثيره جدا لكن
بالامكان اجمالها على نحو الاقتصاد اولا
الابطاء والتاخر في تسميه يعني رؤساء لبعض
الاجهزه الامنيه ما اصابها هذه المؤسسه
يعني هذه الدوائر بنوع من التقاعس ونوع من
الترهل
خطوره تلك المناطق هناك التنظيم يعني كل
محافظه في هذا ظرفها الخاص محافظه ضياء
اللي هي اقرب محافظه شماليه عن بغداد تبعد
اقل من 60 كيلومتر وفيها حدود خطره جدا مع
صلاح الدين عبرهم طيب يجيء والجلام وفي
سلسله جبال الحمرين وحفظ الاعظم وشمال
المقداديه والمخيصه مناطق تكاد تكون الى
الان لم تؤمن بشكل يلبي الطموح فضلا عن
قصور بعض القطاعات الماسكه خصوصا قطعات
قاده الشرطه الاتحاديه ايضا هناك قصور في
المعلوم اذا المعلومه الاستقباريه لم تترى
بشكل الوثي لذلك يعني اذا كانت المعلومه
وصلت بالفعل الى القطاعات الماسكه
القطاعات الماسكيه تتحمل مسؤوليه ذلك واذا
لم تصل المسؤوليه استخبارات فضلا عن ذلك
هناك محافظه صلاح الدين التي تتاخم محافظه
ديالى ايضا لها ظرفها الذي يختلف عن ظرف
دياله بيد انها تحدها ست محافظات بالتغذيه
عكسيه من بينها تقاطع الديوم الذي يشرف
على صحراء حديثه وكذلك اذا المحافظه كركوك
المتاخمه لها والتي تفصلها عن كركوك اخطر
اربع وديان تكاد تكون هي الاخطر على
الاطلاق وادي زغتون وادي الشاي والتقيان
في واديا ثالث يسمى بوادي ام الخناجر فضلا
عن المناطق جنبك التي سياتي على ذكرها طيب
الى الى عمان السيد رعد هاشم سيد رعد يعني
هذه المبررات التي سقها ضيفي من بغداد هل
هي ليحدث ما يحدث ام هناك بالفعل قصور
امني هو الابراز
تحيه لك والضيف الكريم العزيز
واضح فعلا يعني ما ذكره الاخ الزميل فاضل
يعني فيها
واقعيه وفيها
جديه اييي هذا ما نؤكد عليه دائما موضوع
تبادل الاستخباري بالمعلومات وموضوع
الترهل والتهاون حقيقه هناك مؤشر واضح انه
وجود ترهل او وجود لا اباليه لدى القطاعات
الامنيه في مواجهه التحدي التحدي خطير
وداعش يترقب همم
يعني يستمر في موضوع التحرش بالقطاعات
الامنيه لكن تيقد المطلوب لا يناسب خطوره
الهجمات يعني هو داعش يستغل ظروف السياسيه
الكاظميه يعني لماذا الان
بدايه عهد اشعه سوداني
استاذ عبد الله نقول لماذا لم تستغل في
ظرف الاقتتال الذي حصل او هذا التنازع
السياسي الذي حصل على وجهه ولم يستغلوه من
قبل حقيقه هناك من يقول انه يعني فعلا همم
المناصب بتغيير المناصب بعدين داعش همم
يعني هناك من يقول وليس راي هذا انه داعش
يتوجه او يترقب مدى جديه القوات الامنيه
في التعاطي مع الخطر مع كل حكومه جديده
يعني هذا ليس منطقيا كثيره لكن يعني يضاف
لي هذا التخبط في ربما بالجانب الاستقباري
او تغيير المناصب طيب هناك همم قضايا
واقعيه يعني بالمطار بالامطار بالشتاء
كثير من هذه الالغام لاحظت انت العدل
العدد الاستخدامكم
موضوع تفجير اللغم هنا وهناك بسبب الامطار
هذا لا يعد يعني توظيفا واضحا وعمليه
داعشيه حاليه طيب ربما هو لغم قديم لذلك
يجب التنبه والتيقظ الى عدم تضخيم الاجهزه
الرسميه وحتى الاعلام الاعلام الحكومي
والقيادات المشتركه حينما تزور باستمرار
هذا القاطع او ذاك لتضخم الحدث بعض حوادث
هي ربما تكون طبيعيه وبعض حوادث كانت لا
يعطى لها اهتماما بالاعلام الان بعض
الترويجات السياسيه
اذا سمحت لي همم سيد رعد خلي ينتقل الى
السيد فاضل ابو الريف يعني اليوم هل هذه
الحكومه الجديده همم الى الان ما زالت
تتلمس الطريق يعني عاده ما تكون الاجهزه
الامنيه على الاقل منفصله عن السياسيين
حتى يكون جسما واضحا المعالم مهمه همم لا
تستوجب الراحه والرخاء
هو الغفله يعني اول من استاذ عادل استاذ
عادل بالفعل الذي ذكرته هو في عين الصواب
لكننا حينما نقع في عين العاصفه هنا يعني
علينا استدعاء كافه مناسبات وكافه اسباب
الوقوف على الخلل الحادث يعني في
الاسبوعين منقضيين لوحظ ارتفاعه وتيره
الحوالات الماليه والدعم المالي من جديد
التنظيم يحاول ان يبعث الاحياء تاره اخرى
فيما يسمى بدوله التمكين 2014 وما تلاها
لذلك يعني يعني هناك عوامل كثيره
تذهب الى جيوب لا هي تاتي تاتي عبر عبر
مراحل ملتويه هي لا تاتي بصوره مباشره
للحقول دون تمكن الاجهزه الامنيه من
مراقبتها ومن لحاضها ومن وضع اليد عليها
لذلك هي قد هي قد تاتي من من دول معينه
الى محافظه وهذه المحافظه بعدها تسلك ثلاث
محافظات للتشويش والتفضيل والمخادعه حتى
تظل الاجهزه الامنيه
الى فعل ذلك بعد انكسار مكان مكسور هذا
التنظيم وشبه مختفي
يعني بعد ما قتل يعني هناك حدث كبير جدا
لم يسلط الضوء عليه استاذ عادل وهو قبل
ثلاثه اسابيع من الان يعني كان هناك مقتل
مقتل زعيم التنظيم المستحدث بعد عبد الله
قراش وعاده زعيم التنظيم حينما يقتل اما
يتبنى اعلان والكشف النقاب عن رئيس
الولايات المتحده او رئيس العراق ذهبت
ذهبت يعني ذهبت الطقوسيه ان تكون عميقه
الاعلان عبر رئيس الوزراء العراقي او حتى
رئيس الولايات المتحده وهذا معروف انظر
يعني ارجع قليلا يعني بفلاش باك ستجد هذه
الحقيقه معلمه لذلك التنظيم يحاول ان يبعث
رساله الى اتباعه ومريديه يريد ان يقول
لهم نحن باقون نحن احياء نحن لازلنا
نستطيع ان نبادر لذلك مناطق الى الان لم
يتم تطهيرها بصوره مبرمه خذ مثلا مناطق
يعني جبال ماما للمرتفعات بادوش خذ مثلا
مرتفعات الشيخ يونس خذ مثلا المناطق جنوب
شرق كركوك مناطق الحويجه ومناطق الرشاد
ومناطق مكتب خالد خذ مثلا الطارميه يعني
اهالي الطارميه متعاونون الى حد الكفايه
والقدره يعني انا دعما اقول لولا اهالي
ومواطني المواطنين السنه في تلك المناطق
لا ما تحررت تلك المناطق السنه هم الاكثر
تضررا من داعش بيت انهم دفعوا الدماء
اوديه ودفعوا اراضيهم ودفعوا مواشيهم ومع
ذلكم لازال يقاتلون يعني لذلك ما عادت هذه
الخصبه طيب موجوده ومتوفره للتنظيم حتى
يبسط سيطرته وسطوته تاره اخرى في تلك
المناطق طيب سيد رعد يعني هو انتقام كما
يقول استاذ فاضل من بغداد لمقتل زعيم
التنظيم وكيف سيؤثر ذلك على الحكومه سواء
شعبيه يلتف في الشعب حول ما ينتقد هاي وجه
سهام الانتقاد لها ما الذي من الممكن ان
يحدث اذا استمر هكذا جمال
يعني انا بالنسبه لهذا الزعيم الاخير
الزعيم المزعوم يعني ليس ذو شعبيه او حتى
التنظيمات بعض اوجه التنظيمات لا تعرفه
حتى بالاسم ربما استطلعته من صفحات
التواصل او من قبل القنوات او من قبل
وسائل الاعلام لا تتعرف عليه بل البعض
منهم لم يبايعه ولهذا ان يستبعد هذا ضعيف
الاحتمال انا اقول انه هذا داعش بندقيه
ايجار ممكن ان ياجرها اي ارهابي اي مسيس
لا اقول سياسي وانما مسيس يريد ان يغتنم
الفرصه بالبلد الاوضاع وربما من قبل
ميليشيات متخادمه معه لا تريد ان تترك
المناطق المحرره التي عرج عليها زميلي
فاضل همم هناك همم بعض احداث جنائيه حوادث
جنائيه تلصق بداعش
هناك حتى احداث ذو جنب سياسيه تلصق داعش
فاحنا علينا ان نفرز الاحداث بواقعيه يعني
وحتى الاجهزه الامنيه عليها ان تفرز ما هو
الحادث يعني هذا حادث الخالص يعني اشغلونا
فيه وهو طلع حادث جنائي وليس ارهابي وليس
يعني من فعل داعش هذا التضخيم الذي يحصل
مطلوب منه ان يعني حقيقه ان تعزل الافكار
الاتهاميه ليس الدفاعا عن هذا التنظيم
والارهابي وانما لكي تركز ايضا والواقعيه
منو هذا الميلي يا شيخ لا
استاذ عادل هي مناطق واسعه من المناطق
المحرره
واستوطنت فيها فصائل رغم قرار القائد
العام والحالي ورغم الاتفاق السياسي ما
بين الاحزاب على سحب
الفصائل الجيش وتبقى بس الشرطه في المدن
الا انه حينما تتضرر فصائل معينه وهي
مسميات كثيره يعني شردحسب لك هم يبدون من
الفصيل رقم 30 نزولا او صعودا يعني
واضحه معروفه هي يعني موجوده بالمناطق
المحرره ليس جميعها وانما البعض منها
يستغل ظرف هنا وهناك لتصعيد موقف بقصد عدم
الانسحاب فالتاثير على قرار واضح العام
السيد رعد خليني بس اعطيها اخر دقيقه عندي
الى السيد فاضل ابو رغيف تعليقات الاخيره
هل توافق ما قال ضيفي من عمان
يعني اولا استاد راحت عبد الكريم لديه
رؤيه وهي رؤيه محترمه قطعا لكن يعني قد
اختلف معه قليلا اذا تكلمنا بلغه عقديه
الفصائل جميع هذه الميليشيات هي تنتمي الى
مذهب يغير قطعا ويخالف اعتناق ما يذهب
اليه او تذهب اليه تتحدث فيه تلك
التنظيمات الردياليه المختلفه هذه
التنظيمات تكفر من لا يكفر فيقول بمبدا
الكفر التسلسلي بمعنى انها قطعا لن تلتقي
حتى بمصالحها لم تلتقي هي لم تلتقي حتى
البعث هي حتى لم سياسيه لماذا لا تنسحب
يعني ضيفي من عمان كان يقول ليش ما تنسحب
هذه الفصائل بعض هل هو مصلحه ركب لنا
اياها لا لا لا لا قد لنا اياها ههه
ينسحبون عندهم عندهم مصالح اقتصاديه استاذ
عادل عندهم تعايش وعدهم مصالح اقتصاديه
مايرن يخسرون
في اخر الدقائق يعني خلاص
اوكي اوكي يعني
هي اعتقد انها ماسكه بيدها بزمامها على
قواطع المسؤوليه التي تشغلها يعني هناك
مجالس محافظه في كل محافظه
هناك حكومه محليه هناك رؤساء وعرفاء عشائر
هناك اراده السياسيه هي ليست من ذات لون
واحد فقط تكون مليشات تتعدد من مذاهب شتى
القرار قرار سيارته يحتاج الى قرار سياسي
يحتاج الى اجماع سياسي لترتيب البيت
الجغرافي تاره اخرى
استاذ عادل والله منتج البرنامج يقنعني
ويطلب مني يعني هذا الحوار شاكر جزيلا
شكرا جزيلا لكم من همم
الباحثون الامنيه والسياسيه ومن عمان سيد
رعد هاشم الباحث
شكرا جزيلا لكم
[موسيقى]